[Musique]
tous les jours je me réveille dans un
corps différent toujours quelqu'un de
mon âge
jamais très loin du dernier jamais deux
fois la même personne et je n'ai aucun
contrôle sur ce qui m'arrive
12 euros et mis à crier dessus à l'école
j'étais et nuit et le jour où tu es allé
à la plage avec just ngt justin c'est
impossible
au contraire c'est bon tu veux dire que
chaque jour de ta vie tu te réveilles et
j'essaye de vivre cette journée à la
place de cette personne
tu dois te sentir vraiment celle du tout
parce que je sais ce qui rend chaque
personne différente et ce qui rend tout
le monde pareil
pourquoi est ce que tu fais ça le jour
où l'on s'est rencontré j'ai ressenti
quelque chose que j'avais jamais éprouvé
je veux pas perdre sa voix
je suis tellement fière de toi merci
beaucoup
je suis amoureuse de quelqu'un qui
travaille chaque jour dans un corps
différent
toujours le même âge jamais deux fois la
même personne
tu es tellement intelligent beau drôle
gentil je suis un monstre
non tu es un être humain michael on va
rater l'avion sépare avec ma famille à
honolulu frisson me réveiller dans la
peau d'un ado que tu ne reverra plus
jamais aux mondieux sega devrait faire
plus de sport
[Musique]
il faut que j'y aille eh bien c'est qui
celui là
j'oblige alexandra changer de vie et
c'est pas bien qu'est ce que tu veux
dire
bon c'est ce qui arrivera si on reste
ensemble toi et moi ça pourrait marcher
j'aimerais pouvoir te croire
mais qu'est ce qu'il adviendra de ta vie
si je deviens la personne quand tu es
plus proche au monde
[Musique]
j'ai cru que tu étais parti pour de bon
je ferai jamais ça c'est ce que tu fais
tous les jours
[Musique]